this is not gonna be your average
back-end developer roadmap i'm not gonna
tell you to learn python node.js java
ruby any of that stuff we will be
focusing more on the broader
technologies and the tech stack you
should know and figure out if there are
any gaps in your knowledge if you
already are a back-end developer or what
areas you should focus on if you're
trying to become one also if you're new
here make sure you leave a like and
subscribe to the channel hit the bell
icon to receive daily updates from code
dam for tech web development and more
let's go this video is a part of code
dam's t-shirt giveaway program for the
month if you want to take part and win
an amazing go damn t-shirt all you have
to do is leave a comment on this video
about what you think and that's it you
are eligible if your comment gets a
heart from code damn you will win a
t-shirt for absolutely free all right
let's start with the list of very
important topics which as a back-end
developer you should absolutely
absolutely know the first one which
probably nobody expects is http not a
programming language not a database not
a cloud service nothing but actually
through http if i give you a notepad can
you write a simple get request without
actually taking a look at how it works i
mean in a network inspector so if you
have a simple notepad or not even
notepad if i give you a call
cli tool and tell you
you send a raw http request
or using curl or using netcat or any
certain tool can you do that if you can
i mean i'm not telling you to remember
the syntax but i'm actually telling you
that do you even know how to write an
http request if not then probably
chances are you probably don't
understand the http protocol and what do
i mean by that in terms of not
understanding what is a method right
what is the status code what are headers
in a request how does the body work and
how is body different from headers so
you should at least have some level of
semantic understanding of these topics
right that is when you would be able to
say that you understand http protocol
hypertext transfer protocol which is a
plain text protocol so you should be
able to know these differences and what
all these are as a back-end developer
what are the content types for example
if you are receiving content on the
backend is it url encoded is it json
it's json type is it multi-part is it
like you know you're uploading a file
then you need some that sort of content
type so these things you should be able
to understand in terms of how they work
not only on a syntax level but on a some
sort of technical level as well as a
back-end developer the second topic
which comes to my mind is pretty close
to http which we discussed which is the
rest right the rest architecture which i
think we have already covered a bunch of
times i mean in a bunch of videos on
graphql versus rest and i think in the
previous video as well a bit so
rest architecture just states these few
things status codes and using the
correct method name for example and how
to create these rest apis at the back
end so you should be familiar with these
methods like put patch delete and what's
their use case and when you should use
them and so on right similarly if you
want this is again this is an optional
technologies which is slash graphql
right which is technically not an
alternative of rest but i mean it's it's
pretty close right if you just start
your backend and graphql you don't
really need to care about these put
patch posts all the stuff you only have
to care about the schema and how your
data is validated so that is also
something you should consider as a
back-end developer then of course third
thing which comes to my mind is a
programming language right and html
doesn't cut here unfortunately this has
to be a turing complete language which
you can run on a server right so
obviously i'm not here to promote
node.js or python or any other language
you can pick up any language you want
there are so many in the market at the
moment rastnor python every single
language works right there is no bad
popular language if a language is
popular it is probably has some good use
cases pick up a language and try to
connect your language basics to the http
protocol right writing a hello world
program in node.js or a print program in
python or hello world in rust is not
going to teach you how to create http
servers that is a whole another game
because writing http servers essentially
means opening sockets on your operating
system right so you need to have a bit
of networking knowledge as well which
brings me to my next point which is to
actually know about networking and linux
fundamentals which actually comes
networking comes under linux
fundamentals itself but you should be
aware about networking and linux
fundamentals as a back-end developer
because not only you would be working
with the http protocol but in fact you
will be going three levels down to layer
four which is tcp protocol right and at
this point you would actually be
communicating with databases as well
which have their own custom protocols
and stuff like this so you need to
understand how networking works what is
tcp what is http what are the
differences between two till certain
extent i mean not not research level
knowledge but definitely operating
system level knowledge which allows you
to understand what this stuff is then of
course the next thing which comes to my
mind is obviously some sort of database
that could be a sequel that could be a
nosql database that does not matter
initially very much because what you
would see is that nosql and sql both
follow a lot of common patterns tell a
lot of extent right for example indexing
indexing is basically a concept which
you have to understand irrespective of
the database you choose right caching is
another topic which you should
understand as a back-end developer why
caching is required why disks are
expensive than ram why networks are
expensive than ram and so on and so
forth so
understanding about databases
understanding about caching again not to
mention any technology you can use redis
memcache pretty much any technology you
want but really understand how these
services work because as a developer
when the time comes it will not be
absolutely clear to you which technology
you need to use it will only be clear if
you know about the solution space what
exists out there and what you can use
falling on redis and memcache you would
often see that you are using something
known as elasti cache on aws for radius
and stuff so again not to stick to any
particular technology i would say learn
about cloud providers whether this is
google cloud whether this is azure
whether this is aws pick any one which
gives you maximum free credits or you
can jump between them as well but i
would say just pick anyone and try to
embed yourself into that ecosystem right
this embedding inside of ecosystem is
important because fortunately or
unfortunately a bunch of them do have
some proprietary technologies which
results in a vendor lock-in but also
helps you do a lot of things faster
right so you do want to have that
especially at a smaller stage it's fine
it's okay to be vendor locked in but
yeah i mean i would say like especially
when you're learning try to use these
cloud provider services at scale for
example s3 s3s i would say s3 is very
well a window lock in solution because
they don't charge you anything for
uploading to it but they have massive
data transfer charges if you are
downloading from s3 so things like these
right so this is fine if you're doing it
at a small scale but you might want to
reconsider or you know just just see
what you want to do if you are having a
lot of data transfer right so but anyway
the bigger point here is that you should
pick a cloud provider and try to explore
what all is possible right so instead of
using redis on ec2 and managing yourself
try to use a managed service instead of
using a nat gateway on an ec2 try to use
a managed snap-on maybe not because nats
are ridiculously expensive on aws but
for other services like s3 it makes
sense to try these services out number
eight and probably the most important
thing which
most people never mention is web
security and i've made a video on this a
few days back on top five things you
should consider when you're doing web
security and web security is like the
most important thing i would say like
even if you skip cloud providers even if
you skip caching even if you skip db
even if you skip all this knowledge
which kind of is lame because that will
be a prerequisite for web security this
is the rockstar if you are creating a
vulnerable server or if you are creating
a vulnerable application you just put
everything at risk right whatever you're
doing especially the database layer
because code layer is not so fancy right
the actual data which the user data is
the user stuff is that is the value
right anyone can code pretty much i mean
today in today's time if you give a
bunch of computer science engineers from
a college graduate to recreate facebook
they could do that but the data which
facebook has that has value and if
you're writing bad code at an
application layer that what we discussed
in that video if you're writing a bad
code on the business layer the logic
layer
you pretty much are writing bad code for
the world which enables you for all
sorts of attacks and data leaks and
stuff i mean this gets messy so you
don't want to be writing sql injections
and you know that sort of code so make
sure you spend a lot of time on web
security and stuff and understand how
and what are the common practices and
best practices in web security i would
probably put number nine and number 10
in optional so you can learn it if you
want containerization and number 10
testing well you can say they are
optional maybe not
maybe you are someone who thinks that
testing is super important i do feel
that is important but i mean you can you
know just live a little without testing
and containerization as well they'll
certain extent so these are more
high-level production practices but yeah
i mean for containerization again not to
mention any technologies but kubernetes
is an overkill for most things i believe
honestly docker is beautiful you can use
docker for containerization for testing
i would say pretty much this usual the
standard stuff right for back end you
could probably spin up a jest
configuration with some api testing or
you know postman based testing as well
some people do that
i don't i mean i don't have a lot of
experience with postman but yeah i mean
you can play around with these two
technologies but the crux the meat of
the thing
are these rest of the eight things which
are super important i think as a
back-end developer so these were top 10
broader topics i believe are super
important for you as a back-end
developer and if you're missing out on
any of these areas at the moment i would
say like take out some time and figure
out what that area is and try to learn
on that learn more about that so that is
all for this video if you liked it make
sure you leave a like subscribe to the
channel do the comment you know the
drill so that is all for this one i'm
gonna see you in the next video really
soon
[Music]
[Music]